and then we were on this thing I'm
guessing yeah oh that's all the animal
ones for now think I might be gonna
answer alright alright next one Demi
Lovato she might she finally made or she
broke her silence after her overdose so
she made a post about it oh go away
don't worry about it Oh see it's got
y'all right open it what is that oh it's
the vodka oh great oh oh look at the
open access that happens on this show
does knock knock knock
little naki knock knock it's the old
rooster the hola
oh wow oh you producer maybe I'll film
until it's better grain whatever
there is the champs how are you who's
this who's this scary dude are we still
recording not only are you the champ you
decide when this thing goes off the air
yeah
good lord hi Tony hi nice to meet you
how do you wear that squeeze in the rest
you're by love it when you guys roast
each other and just crack each other
just crack each other I apologize man
I'm sorry he does not represent us huh
yeah we gotta figure it out
good to see you though brother nice to
meet you in person I got another one
after this deal huh yeah another one
after this yeah bring them in who the
[ __ ] is that
oh [ __ ] bro oh [ __ ] and you knows
producers with them you know Steve on
himself you got a flat ass so so Theo
I've never met you you got a lot of
hairspray in your hair that gymnasium
that's natural gas Teddy okay
you know where'd you get that [ __ ]
belt feel this right here yeah this um
that did that [ __ ] like online like
how much does that [ __ ] away
want to touch it well look if Brandon
showers right there one spending so much
money on his goddamn socks maybe that
has something nice maybe I'll turn this
real gold I was a hundred percent almost
real gold
that's gold 24-karat so use your head
you know that belt is fake but that's
fake news fake belt no this is a you
tickle that nickel baby this is real
stuff right here man and I'm out there
doing the Lord's work I'm robbing Peter
to pay Paul Zynga's baby all day you
know that poor see yes all day baby I'm
uncomfortable he's a southern Robin Hood
steel baby okay so well let's do a test
right now who's the guest of the year
like ask questions do assess maybe do it
all okay Sam as an impersonal River the
fans did say that Theo von no fan said
it's you out the maryland voted baby no
they didn't yeah white and blue tuefel
baby you know Mike you're being a little
bit of a sore loser right now generate
and go because it was a little sorry it
was Theo
sounds like Lea well he's crystally
winning [ __ ] he was never even the
conversation now we see eye to eye on
something I invented guest of the year
I think I'm 16 did he win it 2016 2004
he won it and then you came in here and
you made a belt up for yourself my
friend do you have a strap daddy he's
asking you I'd like to claim this
thing's heavy man this thing probably
weighs about nine pounds I got that from
Vince McMahon oh this is the or son
maybe so
yeah baby welcome is Happy Days maybe
I'm the Fonz with the bronze daddy you
feel me I'm the Fonz and if you are you
blind
do you want a shot at your [ __ ] you're
moving like Stevie Wonder I've got
butter this is real butter and someone's
getting my eyes baby let me ask you a
question I would like to do a test right
now throws like an old blockbuster I
used to go to spit booths when I was
younger
what's a spit booth I know a German piss
bars are but what's a spit food you
notice booth is ugly
chicken but I've never played anything
like that buna in New York City
what's this pitbull Brian come on use
your [ __ ] brain Vietnamese wishing
well it was the peep booths on 42nd and
you go in there and watch movies and
guys with jerk-offs pit bulls all you
went to spit booth yes
he smells like lube and hairspray that's
America smell like baby that's Aqua Net
it smells like a blockbuster in Aurora
Colorado Oh baby that's diesel gasoline
brother wash my legs with DC now do a
quick test like there's like a thing
here like guess I'm here and like will
let the fans go dude you don't with your
fans did it do you know work Sport
Chalet that's Halloween well this I did
get it on sale the fans voted in he
knows that he knows it and by the way we
and we're doing stem cells donations for
Brian this week this strap will be
continuing to tour America I'm just
stopping it by right here because I
wonder so mr. Michael Rapaport what the
strap looks like he's got that [ __ ] he's
got it is the 10 grand by someone at the
door yeah you want sure okay that's not
true oh well if isn't the redheaded
Slugger himself hey Andrew
what's up bro what's up Andrew Santino
hey Brian what what the hell
he's coming out hot dude hey Tex I said
ride well I don't
I said I didn't know okay I was in
Africa take it easy awesome yeah dude I
saw I saw it it take it easy I just did
this hold on hold on comes there like it
feels entourage what get them out of my
chair crazy dude this is my podcast now
little kid just take over the podcast
for the Rat King the bee sting in the
red rocket you're [ __ ] out rocket is
the PC tonight you come now revolution
has begun Jesus Christ you guys are
fight this is a mutiny don't I hey guys
hey guys what's building yeah kill him
okay say goodbye a box you guys say
goodbye say goodbye to your fans cuz
it's over the time has come say goodbye
to your fans it's over been voted off
the island you've been voted off bro
this is survivor survivor podcast I'm
just old yeah is this new blood in the
old blood right hold my gun man that's
right you feel good about this now
you're done dude we're talking about how
in the new year we're supposed to be
forgiving oh really
we time I guess the year do you guys
pick it already
oh yeah who is it probably tell Theo
what we think tell him no Theo Theo get
the mic no what do we think what
happened well there's good and bad news
you sit in back okay you came in hot
though came in super highly hard play
is a three-man race Santino came in
third I like that now number three
Liat there I carried the day so you did
there's a Cabot you did win there's a
caveat how would I did you won yeah okay
you want tell me no why not tell the rat
when you can come in like the rest
because we closed over 400,000 votes but
there was some foul play four hundred
thousand four hundred thousand I know
what the foul play was well people voted
multiple times that time that's
something but there's some there's some
Russian leak [ __ ] going on or so on it's
some foul play however you draw are you
involved with Russians you're the
closest thing I know to a Russian
probably you are you know he's way more
Russian looking than I am Italian that's
Western Europe you don't look Iranian
bro dude you don't look American out of
me but you look bad bro
Brian looks the most [ __ ] Russian you
look at now you look Eastern European
I'm eating little I do you like soup yet
I mean no Cena yet see no electric right
now this whole couch is shaking you okay
we're giving you ain't Christmas
you're both champs what that's to
channel champs the problem was we didn't
know when we looked at what happened you
guys were so neck-and-neck I'll tell you
all fair the exact details and then
there won't even act like how
neck-and-neck are we talking about
regularity and it didn't make sense and
so we're we've investigated that and it
looks like it's too close to call
there's an intern belt so you you're the
defendant champion then Chris the in
terms you know what this sounds like to
me was in try over there sounds like I
won good to win gets here first of all I
want to thank all my fans and my friends
thank you so much for coming out to
these guys these guys tied I won so this
is your is this your way this is my win
speech let me make a speech real fast
I'm so happy to be guest of the year I
knew it everybody knew it I don't do new
it took Andrus Delano knew it it's
really what happened now that I'm
sitting on top of the mountain it feels
so good it feels so good to be in their
fight now what are you talk oh my god I
can't thank you guys so much I wanna
thank my mom I wanna think
wait till SP can I have my award speech
please no Louis seeker you time you tie
bro you time you like a very weathered
louis c.k [ __ ] huh want to see my
dick huh
i'll Louie CK you write funny now first
yes I would like he's got no please he's
why he's got a real dick on a man's you
really know it looks like I'm not hurt
looks like a red balloon what have you
heard what have you heard huh what have
you heard I've heard like one of the
like a um you know nice Messiah lighters
hold on who's with the multiple colors
what do you mean interim bells but what
are you talking about you guys tied I'll
be honest tie that's what it is to break
this again somebody if you broke that
bro I didn't break hold on I have a
question yeah I got a question who's the
sexy twink who's the sexy full mouth
vide out 20 you who's the sexy full
mouth vide out 20 son wait over there
with with the sweatshirt says
billionaire boys club
young man that's a boy that's our intern
every gay man's dream right yes dude
older gay man I gotta tell you weren't
pants when I Slocombe you all that boy
he's got like your pants shorts on oh
dude shorts one [ __ ] tickle you
tickle them a little bit
that's your new intern beautiful guy
watch you make him wear sweat so he can
take that on and off quickly what sport
can you could you've sparred you move
around it yeah Brian's trying to ask you
to take your shirt off that's all he
really wants no I'm just saying but the
kid looks like we tell through his
sweatshirt that he's he's a beast huh
yeah he's cut up what I call that as I
go kid looks squared away look at the
heels really [ __ ] Matty keeps
throwing looks at shop about don't you
think about my belt broke you tied you
guys tied probably tied belt
do you guys tie chin you [ __ ] live
here
we gotta do a net let's go bye guys
that's it dude thank you for letting me
win that's awesome that's so tight bro i
won yeah we're dancin to it okay I think
you won it's so talking about hey well
the problem is deals go at about an hour
socialite is socially I'd sysm [ __ ] yeah
there's our plate deal and our best
skaters are looking into it
alright brother Fred Chris D'Elia yes
what it is don't say Delano that's so
different I don't know is it now that's
Italy interviews to me I don't give a
[ __ ] about that guy yeah no man you're a
hunter you're a hundred or 95 pound
there's ninety five straight badass [ __ ]
you're going to climb over this desk and
[ __ ] you up a guy I don't problem cuz
you know better no no I know and I
polish that and the life said I don't I
said I don't I said I don't man Lucas
you're so intense loopy you're doing a
red please you too man [ __ ] he's no joke
man he's a [ __ ] crate high belt
you're gonna give him a tie belt dude
leave Louie Alum Rock n leave Louie
alone bro he's leave me alone dude I've
had it you know I've had a tough year
last year good luck with everything guys
there's no calm left in his body
get your hands off our cat dude dude
listen there's you gotta take it easy
we're gonna give you a boat we may have
to give Chris a belt as well as the only
problem we know where the new belts dude
we're or new belts bro hey you did but
you guys in my eyes bro dad yeah oh wow
Andrew you won you won
yeah so [ __ ] you Liz
goddamn attempts Santana is a crazy man
he came at me physically dude he wanted
to hurt you dude how dare you might come
on our show get over here now Bobby
Bobby Lee just knocked on our [ __ ]
door Bobby is the best shirts man last
night shirt was fire too bro what's up
first of all don't don't walk in don't
walk in like you're you know you walk
around like you're on hot coals you you
act all dainty is he gonna be mean bro
and why is your warrior pants a guy came
out to me at The Comedy Store and Kevin
said you know you're really important to
me and I never forgot what you said to
Bobby when he was on your podcast and
and you said to him you got to keep
going
Wow I'm sorry tubes you put out the fire
for the [ __ ] boys that's comedy you're
doing his wow trader Bobby's Bobby's a
trader Bobby's Bobby's jeans
Bobby's jeans are $300 Bobby's ratings
bro will do guess bro you came back from
China you've changed that's not true I
have a very strong voice yes I do
Bobby thanks very podcast appreciate it
man have a good
your neck have a good day guys scholars
your hex man they crashed our podcast
don't ever open the door again for those
people you know I'll see them but he's a
straight-up freak yeah
whoa let's pray feel yeah we gotta give
him his belt where's his belt out check
there
I got like [ __ ] 10 minutes oh hey
Nick it's next morning everybody at the
Hong Kong in actually the 30th of this
month
come on over Nick what's up bro come on
over now I do not like that man we
thought us [ __ ] Jew Samoa dude don't
be so aggressive man you're missing your
legs eating like a gangster no you can't
you can't sue me oh yeah you can't no
you have to do the Hong Kong in the 30th
what's going on not much what are you
doing man oh my god hurt me you don't
even have a [ __ ] operate on me Mike
oh man
damn it Nick you ruin everything here
the crew goes who the fire kid have on
let's get on our show tell me tell me
what's going on Nick Swardson
well talking the Mike [ __ ] talking
the Mike pro-human Brian at the Hong
Kong in oh really
oh I was head bro
lips that go man see this is real
friendship Ryan and run dude you guys
look like the cou this is America bro
[ __ ] just wearing black you're wearing
black
what do you got some Egyptians from Long
Island we're in 19 different colors
a bouncer at a TGI Fridays and be
confident you look like Patrick Swayze
without the pancreatic cancer look at
Nick Sam look at Nick's [ __ ] socks
look at the collar me look like you
robbed a hot powerful Brian like your
rosacea
free doing that if you watch the
episodes we're just chilling yeah
Brian's got this wild capillaries you
look good today brother Wow capillaries
I was told I look healthy you got a
haircut keeping things tight right bro
he got blue eyes you notice that I can't
fold they match one of my Nick folds
over here yes you're very blue doubt
right now yeah the great GQ and I'm blue
we can't all be a [ __ ] Pizza Delivery
mime Hartford where'd you get that chain
from Chuckie Cheese and [ __ ] Fire
Island [ __ ] gypsy at the fire
festival right you look for the sandlot
team dyrdek bro the guy looks like a
[ __ ] raccoon dipped in Gary Busey's
dick sweat oh Jesus
[Laughter]
Brenden look so 11th degree burns I'm
outside that's what Brian washes his
face with my Quivers empty yeah Wow damn
dude
good luck car pool with Brian out of the
Hong Kong I'll Drive my tests loud there
you've been in a real Tesla I haven't
Brian all right my hands in Rome I'm
excited yeah yeah I'm gonna take care of
the kid you can take care of the old Bob
Kahn as I Drive looks like a like the
new rookie on the Brinks truck team
[Laughter]
Billy Ray Cyrus's your spirit animal
whatever Marshawn Lynch died retired
father how dare you oh yeah way to bring
it down he looks like he Shops at us
like with a skill crane bro everything
you wear it's a Hut prized aquariums
[Laughter]
dude Nick what how about your Viking
sucked ass though
boom [ __ ] Italian Lego tape Bergen
you gotta coach the kids oh yeah I think
of that thirteen-year-old kid his pants
back and dope did I enjoy my life just
if you don't travel he goes to tropical
places
yeah dude what's up man what's your
favorite place to go if you like
actually I really enjoy the India the
other yeah dude I'm all right we got a
dip out we're gonna do a podcast yeah
we're gonna do a podcast man I do
podcasting that's gonna talk about you
can't talk about here we're gonna talk
about the Hong Kong in mais xxx put it
on as MySpace and yeah we're doing
podcast next door I know what do you
guys do you guys do um what is it when
you sell all the necklaces and stuff
late at night on television QVC yeah
don't say that you see this QVC it looks
like it yeah no man we got your QVC you
selling a QVC belt Punk is this the belt
it's the belt man oh wow only took seven
months to get around with uh Dustin
place fake belt that's the real thing
there bro this is it huh that's it man I
won this Nick that's good good for you
do you're deserving yeah Nick was up for
the award too you know wow this looks
like the [ __ ] healthiest thing in
Reno
Rose real men do this weighs 70 pounds
more than the other one man Wow oh my
god that's half of Brendan's head Dana
White made that my hand
notice the back Python what's up Nick
what up bro
oh that's python skin huh oh sorry
Siegfried Android that's real fun baby
that's real [ __ ] gone baby that's
what's up they all dope that pen man
thank you guys man you don't mind it
it's our honor I gotta run and Stimpy
bye guys Congrats on your culottes
I put the Hong Kong in just leave that
in this case comes with it oh wow
there's a beautiful cage the holster
brother come to the carrying those
shorts are aggressive the culottes oh
well very unique style yeah
very unique I have style you look like
you own every yellow wolf yellow is a
[ __ ] champ bro I don't [ __ ] with Nick
anymore reason [ __ ] didn't he's a
[ __ ] legend yeah there's a viper damn
dude oh yeah there's a woman who no
there is no son but she looks legit
welcome to strap gana stand baby saying
I got two and if you want them the right
next door I'm gonna get Michael rapper
warts gum from under this [ __ ] table
dude let him get pissed bro in his
mansion dude what he can't buy is to
mother [ __ ] belt baby congratulations
bro it's an X let's take you on the
roads guest starring starring Nick
Swardson and Theo von
very nice there will be the eight okay
you know what I'm saying
what is the HK okay come and do a guest
spot later boys
bye guys see you sweet guys right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]